hello everyone this is
muhammad a teaching and research
assistant at zuwin university of science
and technology at egypt on behalf of my
colleague and my supervisors i'd like to
present our research project titled
predictive analysis of snap disease
association for alzheimer's disease
alzheimer's disease is a slow
progression of memory failure and
language disturbance or judgment and
ultimately this according to the world
health organization's report published
in september 2021
55 million people have dementia
worldwide and it's predicted to reach 78
million in 2030 and
139 million in 2050. the pharmacologic
current
ed treatment do not necessarily slow or
stop the damage and the destruction of
neurons that cause alzheimer's symptoms
and make disease fatal and that's why
the focus of future medicine shifts from
treating existing diseases developing
their progression to preventing diseases
before it sits in
the elevated risk of ed along with the
potential ad preventable strategies that
are recently invented create a crucial
need to discover and validate prognostic
biomarkers that may identify subjects at
greatest risk of developing alzheimer's
disease
although genomic association studies
have been successfully employed to
interrogate the genetic architecture of
common and complex diseases they are
limited for being based on single locus
analysis and they fail to detect the
abscesses interaction between different
likai and their effect on the appearance
of the venous type of interest
the main aim of our project is to
evaluate the impact of different
selection technique for selecting
significant single nucleotide
polymorphism associated with ad
we assess two approaches the first one
is the b value snip selection technique
which depends on the statistical
significance of snips
while the second one is the interaction
selection technique which is a hybrid
approach
that relies on the ability of machine
learning based deselection techniques to
capture the cumulative effect of a small
effect size snips
which is variable in complex diseases
then by building a machine learning
model for each chosen subset of snips
and evaluating their accuracies the
power of each approach is to be assessed
and by revealing the genetic basis of ad
we will manage to build more protective
models for alzheimer's disease
this is an overview of our proposed
framework first our data set was
obtained from national alzheimer's
coordinating center it consists of
364 unique symbols each sample contains
almost
380 thousand snips
the framework applies a pre-processing
stage according to specific quality
control steps to ensure the rata meets
certain criteria such as missing grade
tests and imputation the minor allele
frequency test snip encoding to
represent snips as numeric values
we divided the snips into four batches
according to their b values
and to evaluate the b value snip
selection technique the only snips
that should be used as features
are the ones in batch zero as its snips
b value are
10 to the power of minus five
while the other batches were used in
testing the second selection technique
and assessing the interaction technique
we consider a higher number of snips to
capture the cumulative effect however we
have to keep the number of snips
comparable with the sample size to
assure that the training model will not
overfit the data hence working with the
finite number of data symbols in a high
dimensional feature space we needed to
eliminate some features using a feature
selection method before using another
model to fit the data here we try to
propose
machine learning based feature selection
techniques that rely on different
considerations and the phenotype
association we search for a feature
selection technique that uses the least
number of features to avoid overfitting
and achieve the highest accuracy as well
the feature selection techniques we
tried are mutual information and linear
svc with l1 penalty
as illustrated in the left graph the
best score was achieved by battery 2
that is consist
of
441 snips
whose b value of all of them raised to
10 to the power by the three
bet two achieves higher accuracy than
than
said zero and one using both linear and
rbf kernel with support with support
vector machine model the second approach
is that combine both the value technique
and machine learning approach achieved
better predictive capacity using both
linear and rbf kernels
we mainly depend on neutral information
and machine learning based selection
technique as illustrated in the right
graph the best accuracy achieved
is
93 and have
using 300 snips we can also note that
the higher the number of features we set
the better the achieved accuracy which
supports the first hypothesis of
interaction however the model accuracy
starts to decrease at some point which
may be due to some false positive snips
that we're taking into consideration in
the model
we investigated the ad correlation with
the 300 snips that we computationally
used in decision making to find out if
they are experimentally supported
using nomad database we found that
180 sniffs of them are located in 152
genes by looking them up in literature
we found out
that of the
152 genes there are 104 unique genes
related to alzheimer's disease or other
related diseases as well as 11 ad
correlations with the sniffs themselves
pathway enrichment analysis revealed
that there are 146 pathways associated
with these 300 snips with 26 correlated
pathways to neural system
we try to use setoscape to do network
analysis we graphed the snips along with
the affected genes
nodes represented both the snips and
genes in a network and edge between any
snip and genes indicate the biological
association
then for focused analysis
the nodes with more than three edges are
filtered which means
this genes affected by more than three
snips
looking those seven interesting genes
have we found
the following three genes
are experimentally verified to be
related to alzheimer's disease
to conclude the application of genomic
association studies in case control
setups have resulted in plethora of
significant genetic variants associated
with complex diseases phenotypes
integrating machine learning with the
feature selection technique i would
perform zabi value statistical method
finally our
are to increase the sample size under
examination in terms of having more
patients and to apply the same pipeline
to symbols taken from egyptian patients
with alzheimer's disease because
this neb
brand differentiable
because the snipper and differ
because the snip print differs with
different bibulation we are looking for
creating a personalized health reward
service which enables egyptians to
obtain detailed information and rewards
based on their genome and take
appropriate action
that's it and thank you